another former member of president
Trump's inner circle has agreed to
cooperate with Special Counsel Robert
Muller and what's being called one of
the most significant developments to
date in the Russian election meddling
probe Paul Manafort the president's
former campaign chairman has accepted a
plea deal it follows months of refusals
by manna Ford who is now the fifth
person linked to mr. Trump to plead
guilty to criminal charges
Erol Barnett's at the White House with
the latest aryl good morning good
morning press secretary Sarah Sanders
says Friday's developments have nothing
to do with the president all with the
2016 election the White House trying to
distance itself from the former Trump
aide but with midterm elections fast
approaching that will prove to be
increasingly difficult as special
counsel robert muller games yet another
willing cooperator from the center of
the Trump election strategy over the
last few months President Trump
repeatedly defended the character of the
man chosen to chair his election efforts
while lamenting the existence of the
special counsel probe late Friday
echoing that sentiment telling The Wall
Street Journal quote I got hit with an
artificial witch-hunt that should never
have happened
HS reversing his previous claim mana
fort would not flip attorney Kevin
downing said Friday mana forts wife and
two daughters were at the center of his
decision to share what he knows he
wanted to make sure that his family was
able to remain safe in a DC federal
courtroom mana fort pleaded guilty to
two felony counts stemming from his
foreign lobbying but is also agreeing to
assist the special counsel significantly
cooperating fully truthfully completely
and forthrightly including sharing any
knowledge of all criminal activity and
all documents relevant to the counsels
questions he also agreed to testify at
any proceeding metaphor could answer
questions surrounding the infamous Trump
Tower meeting in 2016 when president
Trump initially said was about adoptions
but mr. Trump's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani admitted was intended to
discuss an exchange of dirt on Hillary
Clinton mana for now joined several
others from the president's orbit who
have pleaded guilty to a crime and
offered up what they know to this
special counsel and Giuliani has said
the president has done nothing wrong but
despite his efforts to get the SPECIAL
councils probe to wrap up before the
midterm elections all indications are
this case will drag beyond that the
special counsel announcing that the
sentencing phase are really a status
update for the sentencing phase of this
DC trial will take place November 16th
Anthony Errol Barnett at the White House
this morning thanks Errol